Game of Thrones fans can attest to a big
truth if you don't pay close enough
attention to what's happening on screen
you'll miss out on a ton of tiny details
this certainly applied to the first
episode of Thrones eighth and final
season the premiere featured plenty of
buzz worthy moments like the
heartwarming reunion between John and
Arya The awkward reunion between John
and bran the dramatic reunion between
bran and Jamie Lannister Plus that
dragon joyride and Jon discovering he's
a Targaryen and Daenerys not giving a
single hoot about telling Sam she burned
his family alive don't be allowed home
again now that my brother's the doll
what has people talking even more than
all that are the two blink and you'll
miss them cameos that most people didn't
pick up on the first time around you
know on account of everything else
happening during the episode in the
season 8 premiere there's a scene in
which Theon Greyjoy storms his uncle
Euron's ship making his way to his
sister Yara before he can rescue her
however Theon has to pick off a few
members of Euron's fleet Theon's hand is
steady as he fires an arrow clean into
the back of one man's skull sending it
shooting out his eye he and two men
behind him put several more arrows
through the heads of other random guys
on deck the siege is successful the path
to Yara is clear and Theon is free to
return to Winterfell while Yara looks
over the Ironborn as queen of the Iron
Islands on the surface the scene doesn't
seem out of the ordinary it's a
calculated act of violence executed to
meet an end goal look closer at the
people playing Theon's victims however
and you'll see that the sequence is
anything but normal
as it features cameo appearances from
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia actor
Rob McElhenney and Silicon Valley star
Martin star io they aren't on screen for
very long and the dim lighting makes it
difficult to recognize their faces so
it's easy to see why so many never
caught McElhenney and star on the season
8 premiere of Fame of Thrones well
they'll be cutting from your face to his
face
and back to your face and we'll get to
see his face again with each passing
season the series has gotten better at
sneaking in celebrity cameos that only
the most eagle-eyed viewers can
immediately find over the years Game of
Thrones showrunners David Benioff and DB
Weiss have managed to include musicians
other actors and even political figures
on their series even Weiss and Benioff
themselves made cameo appearances their
mugs scene in the Hall of faces at the
house of black and white
and very few could forget the time
singer-songwriter ed Sheeran appeared on
Thrones playing a singing Lannister
bannermen arya met as she was traveling
to King's Landing
while many Game of Thrones fans weren't
keen on Sharon's cameo most everyone is
loving that McElhenney and star got to
be part of the series if only for a few
seconds in a way it marks a full-circle
moment McElhenney is close friends with
Benioff and Weiss who previously wrote
the season nine It's Always Sunny
episode flowers for Charlie and made
their own small appearances on the
season 12 installment the gang goes to a
water park
a long time Thrones fan McElhenney was
thought to have already cameoed on the
show back in season 6 appearing
alongside his always sunny co-star
Charlie Day as unsullied soldiers but
that ended up being just a rumor like
what's that rascal Charlie unfortunately
there's one person who definitely won't
appear in the final season of Game of
Thrones the mastermind behind the whole
thing
george RR martin as it turns out the a
song of Fire and Ice
author had the opportunity to cameo on
season 8 but turned it down in favor of
working on finishing the winds of winter
the long awaited sixth book in his novel
series upon which the show is based in
the Game of Thrones cameos you either
accept and play a character who probably
dies or you decline and deliver on your
past promises McElhenney and star may
have had more fun but Martin's chose
wisely check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Game of Thrones are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]